so uh let's start out Jason with that
time jump I mean shows you times up
sometimes but six years is a big one you
know why did you decide you know let's
let's do this now I mean we've talked
before about the show actually it was a
pretty condensed time period for the
characters tonight you're leaping
forward what does it feel like okay
let's let's do this down well we talk a
lot less season about how the world
would not be survivable for five years
and so because I know he's got heated
wearing hazmat suits figure let's jump
ahead so they could come out without a
contractors thank you actually we can ad
shows it on a car I wait what can you
say about that prisoner ship because
that's a whole new element add to the
serious point well without spoiling too
much of the prison ship there from her I
think I've heard some speculation that
maybe they weren't and it's there from
our time so they're from for the first
apocalypse which is a spoiler but okay
and that is that huge probably cry over
they were in hypersleep for a hundred
years I think that was planted in
certain episodes last year that they
have that time capability so they come
back to the planet that they don't
recognize that it has been destroyed I
just left it twice and all that left is
this Garden of Eden that Clark's been
living in with her daughter you know it
will not be big enough for everybody so
the lines let's talk about Maddie who's
not her biological daughter but we
talked about what do you think about the
time jump but here they're doing it and
about this new character that's gonna be
so crucial to Clark well I've been
playing a nineteen-year-old for years
since I was 23
so it's like it's nice to be a three
playing someone a little close to my age
we were going to get away with that and
yet I think it's exciting to see you
know it will be there's like you know me
and as I guess being a 24 year old woman
who has gone through so much and she's
taking on this paternal role looking
after this little tiny knifeless
Bob you know with when Clark thought she
might not make it which are not to be
the truth you know she kind of was
passing on leadership to him to Bellamy
you know he's gone through a lot up
prior to that you know didn't think this
was a challenge he had risen to in those
six years I'd like to think that he had
I think the he has taken the advice as a
hit in the heart
I mean from what I've been told I don't
know that much other so I guess from
what up what Jason is told me if he can
be trusted
Penelope has grown up a little bit I
think but yeah that sixties on jumps
kind of crazy becoming six months for us
but we got to figure out what they've
done to their lost cookies and on this
character p.m. yeah yeah yeah it got to
be a reset sort of for all you guys and
Murray with Octavia I mean she was put
in charge of a lot of people and we saw
in the finale the insecurity she had
about that and she was a character was
so much sort of on the fringe and
literally had to hide her most of her
life
what do you think it's been like her to
now be in a spotlight in this way after
all the sort of on the one um I think
Octavia doesn't have a clue what she's
doing but she doesn't wanna you know set
off the chaos with this 1200 people in
the bunker because it was her idea to
throat have one crew and have this mixed
bag of plans and of course they're not
wanting to let go of previous animosity
that they have for one another so just
similar to the way she was trapped under
the floor on the ark
same thing is kind of going in the
bunker where you know you can't just run
around and break the laws and cause
riots in in season five you'll see in
fact what Octavius plan is to keep the
peace and how she reprimands others in
her
special way for special way
that's not deploy there won't be a
peaceful way possibly with the you know
healing everything that I'd say readers
would throw a lot of a sea benefit you
know but now I mean we saw in that
finale you know how essential she was
just getting them saving them getting
off the planet do you think that in this
situation they've been in all these
years that she sort of thrived I mean I
could feel it's a small group up there
but she would be a very key member of
that group you know ravenous is so
special because she is so smart and she
you know is a key ingredient I feel in
the hundreds makes and for their
survival but I think also you know Bill
Raven so smart you know her heart weighs
on her a lot
the only reason why everyone is in Spain
is because of reason Ravens leg clavicle
myself that it was just like more like
some someone come pick me out because I
want to go to bunker and her friends are
like yeah of course we'll be there in
ten minutes
and boots were tough now what do we do
so I think Raven has a lot of
responsibility for everyone's well-being
he's Dave and that's why you know her to
humans this Facebook finale was so
important for her and now in space it's
a lot for her to make sure that
everyone's survivable and that we can
hopefully get back down to the earth and
wasn't a visible again and she Pritchard
you kind of like Octavia if you were
Murphy was an outsider character for a
long time that sort of changed a lot
last season he was sort of making amends
with Raven right Nia yeah come on
and then we thought even Bondi uses
internal works and stuff out you know
Jesus
[Laughter]
it's really convenient I feel like
that's a character that will especially
be fascinating to see a cute in six
years because now he was with these
people do you think that he might be
really change from all this a hundred
percent I mean I think all of us have to
change up their league instead of six
year jump is some is a great challenge
but it's also really freeing of a lot of
ways and kind of kind of taken the
shackles off of you of all the decisions
you've made with your character over six
years I mean a lot of therapy can happen
in that time you can know that you can
leave behind a lot of what we've been
doing or keep some of it if you want but
obviously he's going to change because
he's so good in kind of like the
pressure cooker situations and thriving
with his life on the line every day and
now in space more so just living day to
day and making it to the time they can
go back home that's very different for
him so I'm curious to see if now that he
has nothing that kind of like fight
against can he really just be part of a
happy family I'm curious to see how that
goes
is he bored little troublemakers oh he's
got to find a way to have some fun you
know Chris you know it is funny when you
think about the timeline of the shows
because it was just a few months with
the characters so it's like thinking
about a tough few months for Monty found
his dad died had to shoot his possessed
mom his best friend died in his arm
diello wasn't what's your what's your
question and it's not to be Monty know
my question is actually about Harper and
Monty and just the fact that you know
would that make that connection even
stronger given sort of all the loss that
he's gone through I think that Harper is
Monty's main lifeline at the current
moment and has been for six years I
think given the loss of Jasper if he
lost Harper as well I'm not sure he
would have made it out of Arcadia so I
think that he owes or his life and she
chose him and I don't know what the
results one of the last six years has
been I hope they're still together but
even if they're not
they have you skated everything they had
because I think they deserve that I know
he knows maybe mocking butter fear
together now we can cry a lot can change
in secures Dean this is such an
ambitious show you know you look at the
finale and how much you had going on is
it just a continuing fun but also crazy
challenging things to work on this
series and see how much they throw you
and how much they're doing within you
know forty four minutes a week you guys
haven't met him before but this man is
like very responsible as well these days
inferred for the kick-ass show that is
100 yeah you know one episode that
really stands out to me this past season
in the entire series actually is die all
by merrily maybe in the conclave episode
it's typical hundred fashion it was also
pretty merciless and you lost a lot
notable characters Jason at what point
developing keyboard as you know that you
want to do that to worry that episode
pretty early on that was kind of you
know every season we have these tentpole
moments of reining for that was the big
one
one of the big ones last year was
written by Aaron wake in Bergen McEntire
great writers my number two's on the
writing staff and Dean directions that
he'll really just it's as good as we've
got I think it was it was everything
came together Murray was awesome she
really encouraged her ass off again I
mean I probably more great time than
she's ever had and you know we just when
I look at that I feel like we've done
this now for five years your team in
Vancouver is amazing everybody sort all
the actors are titling it's really fun
to be working in a show now where we
know what we're doing we know you know
what we can do we know how far we can
push them I don't try to push too hard
beam know why I thought I'd like to try
to challenge everybody so you
we can have this sort of pelty that
episode was also sort of a t14 echo who
I don't think any we could see could
have guessed where her path was going to
go talk about you know what you said to
do with her there and how things sort of
change further there I think instead of
me answering that why don't we bring out
a special guest
[Applause]
they're Tasi our hello there
so yeah yeah I've been saying one of you
heard you guys were cheering in the
posse is now it's regular Java show
echoed a girl in the cage and season two
a lot changed what we think of her we
know about her oh it didn't like for you
to kind of track tracker this entire way
and see where she's gone hello
it's been amazing every time we got a
script those nervous to to explore more
in TECO and give life to that character
and she was always the character that I
felt really strongly about she was sassy
she's cool I love it when she's bad not
felony face you want an echo eats for
breakfast oh how is years ago
that's a week you yeah okay Mia got ones
needed here I got the biggest movie ever
you who will spin a totally favorite
season fun
but yeah it's very credible
Lindsey I referenced this why don't I
introduce you but yeah this is Raven
Reyes and I'm alive with such a great
moment on the show you know let's talk
about that episode the other side which
was you know another Raven goes through
hell episode but only I can build that
that entire sequence of the water
crawling across the floor that badass I
feel like you know I so I so love with
this show because it's my own selfish
after needs because they're constantly
challenged these
physically emotionally act acting truly
and that absolutely helped them cuz I'm
in this tank that I asked to be freezing
to death and have these really emotional
/ figment of my imagination have been
losing my mind and then I kill myself
and then I resurrect it with the
electric shock underwater and have a
heart attack and throw myself over it
and crawl to a defibrillator that the
cross Oh
Ilana stick it on the right place and
jolt my heart back to life because of my
heart murmur and I want to talk to my
friend it was it was insane but it was
honestly like in you suggested that one
he was with me every step of the way and
it was you know we did some really cool
things to where I just felt like I was
coming back on the ground he walked me
through this like a magic story about
what I'm going through my mind and it
was it was kind of a surreal experience
that I just really I just feel like no
other show I'm going to be able to get
and do that like free it's like it's a
dream job like what do you do that never
so it is then I would call it hell venom
heaven pinaster way yeah dirty actor I
think definitely that's certainly
something that this cast goes through
more than any cast really I've ever
worked with we do so much physical stuff
on a show a lot of them do 80% 90% of
their own stunts which is kind of
amazing the weather in Vancouver starts
out really hot and then it gets rainy
and then it gets snowy and cold and
we're out in it 14 hours a day so it
never wants I mean they're pros and it's
it's really been fun I believe last year
sitting on this very stage version of
Chris you know there was a lot of talk
in other people's - about
lamenting cuz you to like never work
together
so what was it like you finally get to
work together and the fact is that you
know your characters had to deal with
some of the old issues because they
hadn't been on screen together
yeah I mean one time we'd been together
before season four woods I just tried to
kill his best friend or like coughing
yeah Goldberg yes of course I think that
was where we had to one thing we had so
we had to play with that Frasier eerie
force Jason's hands with that one but
forcing us down so glad it was good idea
we had it's funny you know there's so
many actors in the cast that it's hard
to find you know I took that surprised
me that they had never been in a CBS and
though when I wrote the scene I did have
to sort of go back to the beginning and
sort of call after that moment in
episode what would that so 103 103 is
this one that was the one that fell away
was out of the camp and I took it right
myself to leader and exactly what think
West I think say how do you feel about
me I please the fit no it's been great
it's been great Richard I'm glad to
finding out screen time this is yeah
they're little year anniversary
[Laughter]
if I preview 100 soap opera they were
Network get bored in space
Sofia can you talk about you know it
just echo like these people do not have
a lot of reasons to trust I go clearly
it was a very tense situation even her
joining them so or you know I don't know
how much you know about what it's going
to be like the six-year job but are you
excited to see how things that developed
because that's so much time that it's
just a small group of people spending
together yeah I actually am thinking
about that a lot like who should become
friends with like I was thinking would
she become friends with Louisa or would
she become friends with other
castigation be close to Raven for some
reason yes I feel like these two girls
or girls a guessing times a very
resourceful they are dad to see those
two like becoming friends and having
alliances where two years of a long time
yeah we forget together break up the
back together together that's the thing
you know Jason Knight I'm I don't have
the shipping question that's not my deal
but six years yes you use a lot of
rocket look at when it is coupled the
reason were not part of a couple how
many things have changed like I said
things people break up you will get back
together
full fool around I mean they do have
secures of time to kill and there's not
a lot to do
Jolyon faithful Ravens really long oh
and then I have to ask you this I hope
you've ended but uh you know whether it
be the bunker or the rocket her baby
that's going to be showing up with you I
know you would sing a little would be
from another
well no but Clark has one you won't have
to get pregnant but she has to be
preventing child together fun passport
we're going to go to audience questions
if you visit but has depression or later
I'm going to have Randy Fox acne podcast
is everyone going to undergo a change
that puritans amplified emphasized of
the six year jump like how Clark cut her
hair and color part of its will there be
will be some eye patches so no bowlegs
it's actually a lot because usually
we're picking right back up where we
left off except right things the one
season we found is are killing panic
oriented and so they're literally these
guys go off on their hiatus and they to
movies or they relax you whatever do
when they grow their hair and they cut
their hair and they dye their hair we
gotta get it back to where it was you
know exact exact moment but this season
is different and I've really talked to
all of them about what are they because
anything is possible
after six years so I'm open to it Bob
and I have been talking guys to kind of
crazy aha well the funny thing is is
dialed in already have already know that
you know it's pressuring me for some
weird hair dude you want to share with
them no I don't want if you're going 300
you clearly don't like it we've done
that I don't agree well Bob we have an
also ghost because other people asked
about the appearance change but I got a
very specific one from hath eternal baby
saying Oh Bellamy has a beard or a lot -
yeah like it is not just a back door
game though being very back I can't
really love that one on this but I can't
really grow a bit so you know we're kind
of discussing that now and factoring it
in terms of BH budget donation we don't
have a budget Bobby appeared with big
Cypress I got a big montage oh yeah
he'll get fired up what's your talking
with a pair feel cool yeah yeah I mean
are you down with that this week - yeah
we got - open on a close-up of the
impression is my - yeah I mean I'm open
to it
okay cool mustache sure just really we
have to succeed minor felonies like
carving that good thing now Connie on
the radio really asked a relevant ask
that it's inevitable that we get
flashbacks during the six year time jump
would that be how the season starts
does it start from right where we left
off might there be some flashbacks
catching us up
yeah they'll be flashbacks for sure
there's a lot of very pivotal emotional
intense moments that we will have missed
in that six year period I think it's
important to see some of them not going
to spoil the premiere yet but we will
come to understand how all of them
became the characters that we will see
in the premiere
yes that does include flashback hi I'm
Jonah what I was wondering is that all
the character of the show are so complex
they wanted them later
funny what's your favorite had to do
tortures or trees of your character I
don't know I like a headlock clock
resilience I guess is something that I
like and there's a lot of selflessness
to her which makes me happy
I mean I admire only a belamis present
if you had to get up and everyday no
he's made so many important choices and
still try and assist and get things done
but the thing that I personally like
about it the most is his ability to hold
on to guilt I mean no but honestly it
sounded fun to play in that realm and
everything so weighted down so as an
actor I I like it when he's in tune with
that part of himself
so yeah sounds I like how incredibly
flawed Octavia is and she's always brave
in the face of fear I like that about it
I love Ravens will I feel like she when
she puts her mind to something she is
unstoppable and it's admirable that you
know because I think for me like I don't
get bogged down but you know Raven Reyes
never gives up I love it
I don't do it it's kind of similar time
okay it's kind of similar to will or
Brazilian
but as there is relentlessness it's not
even like a calculated resilience it's
just this pure like animalistic will to
continue whatever grade she's on the
pocket and I never had exactly how
groups never done and I think yeah he's
just he's like a wild dog I love them my
God my god sexy Gail did you all know
that Monty can make alcohol from scratch
makes moonshine in like three weeks down
on the ground I think that's pretty cool
is it is that your favorite
characteristic yeah I think I like at
those strengths and her loyalties most
she never backed down from a fight she's
always protecting her plan first and
yeah thank you very much
next question see hi I'm AJ you guys
can't give me a heart attack with like
all the years of stuff I can't take it
oh but I hope you guys never die what
did you do how would you want to go out
and I see the characters other
someone else talking son might go out
the way Raven would God have to go out
stay we are talking with character you
personally would like me yeah it's down
at this thing yeah to be back behind I
want Bellamy to kill them I think we've
come a long way but I think if there is
their happiness I like double turn or
something alright and you have to just
put me down and I think that be read
like a come a long way like I like you
can yell all right right yeah yeah one
way or another I think we do right you
could be right of one of us to have the
other eventually and ask Nona
- building just have a misstep and fall
off the edge of the cliff
thank something like you would I think
I'd say the only just bought four
horsemen gallant and I get stepped on or
something it would hurt her ego less and
to get taken out by some brie oh yeah
god I don't know I mean realistically
collectively some sort of grand
self-sacrifice
yeah it's not that funny but you would
go out alone problem no I could Jennifer
yeah yeah
who Chris talked to one two three one
two three
Hey okay I'd like for equitable Monty in
sleeper hold kind of accidentally take
him out no one's like navigated a
peacefully in his sleep
I like your costume by the way thank you
very much big question all right man hey
hey okay
hi so we know that secures past and
Clark is now mom but I was just
wondering what type of parenting styles
does the car have and it has been six
years so all of you might be surrogate
parents what kind of parenting style
will your characters clarks a cool mom
yes mom
come on let me get our man don't be a
mess
yeah oh yeah that's like at page five
we're like okay now this is a rifle how
to drive a robot Luther Connors are
coming to remember like yeah raise her
to be prepared in case yeah yeah better
job with her than me Charlotte we were
terrible only we can tell that she's
privates in the real know that she's
telling her tonight stories that also
end with you know murder and death yeah
thank you there's no moving the Clark
has been telling stories up you guys
these are Maddie's heroes when we when
we started that was going to be another
letdown when she painted your belly fat
mustache I was just wondering now the
show is kind of come full circle with
the original art residents being the
grounders what parallels are we
conceived between season one and the
upcoming season that's a really good
question yeah one of the things that
excited me about this idea bringing
these prisoners into the world was that
five seasons ago
these guys with prisoners and now Clark
is the grounder in the woods who's
watching these people step out very
different cast of characters that
they're about to have to deal with but
that parallel will continue for sure
we'll play with that quite a lot this
season and they'll realize it I think
the Bellamy is going to have to help
Clark come to see that you know there's
we have to do things differently now
because she just wanted to protect her
child she just wants to protect her home
so thank you very much
[Music]
can I hold your baby balloon we're
working on America our question is a 6
years to be a long time sit around in a
big kitchen whether you're underground
she wants to meet you super bot I'll
introduce you our new center enjoy all
right this is why we have no babies on
the show but we've got one if you need
bread ha ha ha ha she's used to make
character look good the life is like
trying her in it all right we have a
running series that certainly Miller and
Jackson are going to get together with
some of the grounders of informa WWE so
what other kinds of hobbies you think
your characters are going to put
together - uh I think that without
whiskers you guys what I'll not pitch to
the story I'm old habits die hard
let's go back to being a janitor
grooming again it's really all about the
cleanliness yeah that's gonna be spent
yeah and a big conference like Freddie
Mercury yes yeah no joke which was a
frame where he's and then also are you
do pull-ups
anyone whatever anyone else I was - like
Raven for her to learn to the fight you
know you don't only be raving it's you
too much combat so I know you all right
then I'm good
alright I think it will be our final
question hey guys and fellies memory oh
you've got potential reasons yeah your
wedding I wanted you wanted my question
is actually since you talked about
fighting I mysterious how often you get
to rehearse before you buy what the
process is to kind of learn suffice and
then like I put this on today and it
seems hard to fight and like see if
awareness how did you do that before you
actually shot or was it like step into
it wheels the swords kind of thing this
is a very good question um the cool
thing is about sword fighting to
basically put it in a quick nutshell
here is that it's kind of like learning
dance like there's the alert a dance
routine and that's the way it is and
it's all numbered out and we do it
slowly and I've named all the moves
so I write them down and when I get home
I was given a wooden sword as a gift and
I just sit in my living room when I
practice so one's called like
chick-fil-a the Sam and I call another
one like silly name so I remember it and
i memorize my fights but sometimes you
get a ton of time and sometimes you
don't have schedules change and stuff
but if you really just I don't know I'm
really good at a really useless life
skill on my luggage horse fighter
yeah there's always there's always stuff
rehearsal we have you know we find time
on days when they're not working there
at the end of days when they're not
doing the stunts to go over to Marshall
virtues our stunt coordinator has been
season one and is amazing and he puts
them through their paces and they
rehearse sometimes we don't have time
for that she's right and they just make
this stuff up today
it'll call it on the on the big ones for
sure we do it because look if safety is
always an issue you know with the stunt
work so on the big stunt sequences like
in dialed I merrily we each one of those
was a little dance
we the director who was me on that one
works with Marshall and says this is
kind of what I'm thinking I want it to
look like this he goes and reverses with
the stunt guys shows it to me videotapes
it and shows it to me
I go I like that that's change that and
then he brings these guys in and they
get to learn and then I look at it again
I say yeah that's exactly what I want we
show up on the day sometimes it's
exactly will be rehearsed sometimes
where we will tell you what can I do it
like this and so we'll change one or two
little moves that's basically how it
goes
I put a clip of marine or living room
like thanks Angela
[Music]